I have an announcement to make okay I
watched anime I was okay this is this is
[__] weird right because I was like I
was about to say I'm the host for today
I'm hijacking this show we're talking
about anime because it's been a while
since we had anime top uh anime title in
one of our episodes you know what's
crazy Connor I also watched it are you
[__] for it was it chainsaw man no I
watched I watched an anime film actually
I watched two anime films yesterday
which is what is going on what is going
on over again holy [__] I'm having
flashbacks
the good old days
and I watched three shows oh [__] three
shows I don't know how to start the
subscribers let's let's go with Joey
first that's because uh okay because
it's it's a rarity whenever I get to
hear a joke
[__] that I don't [__] care about I
like how every time Joey talks about
anime my first reaction is
okay so I watched I just on a whim I
think uh because I was talking to my
friend about uh the late Satoshi Khan
all right easily one of the most like
groundbreaking influential unique anime
directors of all time and I thought to
myself I was like damn I haven't watched
a lot of Satoshi Khan in a while okay
okay and I thought to myself all right
I'm probably gonna try and find if there
are any Satoshi Khan films on Netflix so
I had some time uh the only one that
Netflix Japan has is Millennium actress
I thought that's good which which is oh
which I was glad because I was like I've
seen perfect blue plenty of times to
remember it I've seen paprika enough
times I've seen tiger Godfather's
Millennium actress though I feel like
I've only watched it once and it was
like decades ago yeah so I was like all
right perfect I'll like refresh myself
on Millennium actress because I
literally don't remember anything about
it
[__] brilliant film like I know it
wasn't a surprise because it's Satoshi
wow biggest Revelation guys Joey
rediscovers that Millennium actress is
in fact a good movie yeah um but man
like re-watching that film just made me
real I mean for one it came out in 2001.
can you believe that it's a 22 year old
film no idea and it still looks [__]
incredible to this day yeah I mean
Millennium match I don't like you said
about watching Satoshi Khan films he's
not made a bad film no I mean he's only
made four yeah exactly he's only made
four the only thing arguable about him
making a bad film is probably dream
machine because he didn't finish because
he didn't get to finish that that's the
closest he's come to making a bad film
can you can you imagine just having such
a perfect filmography that your only bad
entry is the one that you didn't finish
because you died before it finished
what's he up to is he just like living
off the wages of those four no he's uh
he's dead he's dead
yeah he died like 10
I was like why is he foreign
yeah I mean unfortunately he is one of
the greatest tragedies in the anime
industry because I don't know anything
about him I just know that he made the
films that people like yeah yeah
I've seen um
right right that was very good I think I
spoke about it on trash days yeah yes he
did yeah I really like that film I
didn't know who's dead yeah yeah
unfortunately like he is in all of anime
history probably one of the most
talented directors and filmmakers to
ever come out of Japan
um and he has made stuff that has not
only like aged wonderfully he was he was
like years ahead of his time he was so
ahead of his time that Hollywood film
directors has taken his ideas and some
of his individual scenes and put them
into their own Hollywood films I mean
there are literally like some scenes in
Requiem for a Dream that are just a
one-to-one copy of scenes from perfect
yeah yeah exactly
um um how did he die he died of prostate
cancer I believe it's all [__]
pancreatic cancer yeah
um but yeah so Millennium actress is his
second film the one he did after perfect
blue that was his first film yeah that
was his first film some people just wake
up and just immediately hit oh no I'll
make a film and yeah it's gonna change
everything he literally
just woke I was like I'm gonna make one
of the greatest anime films ever like
man you got to try and show how do we
get like there's magic wakes up he's
like I'm gonna make a film that's gonna
be well I'm sure you trained a lot but
I'm just joking but like that's insane
that his first film is that good did you
know that he actually did some scenes in
Akira of course he did yeah but um
anyway so yeah I rewatched rewatch
Millennium actress basically to to sum
up the film it's so hard to sum up a
Satoshi Khan film but basically
Millennium actress is about this actress
who is like you know past her prime I
think it's like 70-year career or
something and she uh films this
documentary about her life reflecting on
her life and how she went into the
acting industry because she met this
random dude who he she doesn't know the
name of doesn't even remember the face
of but it was basically her first love
when she was a child
um and so she goes into the acting in a
world in the hopes that she can get
famous enough that the guy will
recognize her on the big screen and that
they can meet again essentially
um but what is so brilliant about this
film is the fact fact that like every
Satoshi con film it's he does this
brilliant job of like mixing in
different Realms of reality throughout
the movie so it's like you watch a scene
in Millennium actress and you go okay is
this just a scene out of a movie she
acted in or is this a metaphor for what
what's going on in a real life at the
time or is it actually a depiction of
original most teachers be like no but
like you know I mean as cliche as it
sounds though like it is fun it's purely
like that and the way that like Satoshi
Khan transitions into these scenes like
you could be getting used to one scene
and then half a second later it
transitions into a completely different
film and the entire time you're like is
this a recreation of the movie she was
in or is this her telling her story
through the movies that she was in yeah
I think one thing that makes him just a
[__] genius in terms of like
cinematography and just a Storyteller is
that the way he is able to transition
between scenes is
completely seamless yeah it's unreal
um and he uses this in such an
interesting way in films like Millennium
actress and perfect blue where I think
Millennium actress
um is she tells her life story but she
tells you you see her life story through
the lens of basically a movie right
um and it's got references to a lot of
movies and a lot of different genres so
it's kind of this you going in and out
of reality being like Oh you're
wondering if this scene that she's
showing us is a movie that she acted in
or is it a scene that happened in her
actual life and there's no real you know
it's there's no real line between what
is real and what is on film but yeah
it's just the way he uses that as a way
to tell her life story it's just [__]
genius yeah and it's like and it's this
other brilliant thing and I picked up so
many new things on Millennium actress I
didn't pick up the first time around
like for example like you know the first
half of the film you know as she's
telling her life story of like I met
this guy I you know I fell in love with
him I went to the big city to you know
pursue a career to you know hopefully
meet him one day and I did all of these
different kinds of movies and you know
built up these roles and went through
these hardships of becoming a big
actress and then the second half of the
movie uses those exact same scenes and
the in but in a completely different
context so basically he somehow as you
get to know about this actress and the
hardships which she went through in her
real life they then replay a lot of
those scenes in the second half but now
you're looking at it through the lens of
her real life off the screen oh I see I
see and so and and so like you know for
anyone who's watched Millennium actress
you'd know the first literally the first
scene of the film and the last scene of
the film is the exact same scene but the
context behind it is completely flipped
on its head it's pretty cool you watch
the first scene and you're like oh this
is a movie this is in the context of a
movie she's in a space suit and she's
going to space saying you know I have to
go and meet this person right and it's
all all in the context of film and you
know it's in the context of a film but
then they reuse that exact same scene
with the exact same dialogue and now it
means something completely different
that's cool and he does it I don't know
how the [__] he did it but he made that
so seamless throughout an hour and 20
long movie like it's not a long movie at
all I remember when films used to be an
hour and 20. yeah right oh
um I feel so meaningless to be like hey
this amazing experience give it a score
out of 10. oh [__] I mean is it like is
it like would you say it's like as close
to a perfect film in your mind
giving score
well I think you explain this like
amazing thing and I'm like aha give
score see because in school eight out of
ten please it actually made me like want
to make a video of like uh Satoshi con
worse to best but like then I realized
after watching Millennium actress I was
like he doesn't have a worst yeah like
it's it's like literally the most
perfect what do you say filmography best
from bestest then yeah
least least strongest yeah most
strongest any of them are not strong
yeah but like I just like you know I
kind of just like rediscovered like why
I love this guy's films and even like
the manga I rediscovered why I love it
I could never but like it made me and so
like uh over the next 10 seconds yeah
yeah oh by the way change them in 10 out
of ten obviously okay I'm mocking my
wolf off
uh then uh then I was like uh I also
watched a new film this time I watched
uh this movie called ride the wave which
is uh masaki Us's latest film uh I say
latest film because it came out in like
2021 I think yeah um I I I I didn't get
to see any Cinema I could be totally
wrong I thought that looked like ass am
I am I crazy
you think I I saw the trailer and I
thought nah dog not for me no I mean I
think am I crazy I think out of us I
think out of like Us's filmography it's
probably one of his prettiest films wait
no wait crap is he the guy who makes the
same movie and over again or is it a
different guy no that's uh that's my
Turkish he makes the same movie yeah
yeah I can't watch it USA is the one who
did double man cry baby yeah oh okay
another man cry baby ping pong the
animation
I feel like I saw the trailer for this
film and I thought I I don't get it okay
I have I have two reactions when I see
uh you ask a film yeah uh my first
reaction is what the [__] okay did
someone Reign him in with the plot for
this because if you let me masaki you
ask to do what he wants it just goes a
direction where you're like uh up
that's what happens just like what the
[__] is this like I remember watching uh
I think he's uh I can't remember the
name of the film mind game yeah uh
never heard of anime okay yeah mind game
I don't even know how to explain that to
someone who what the film let alone
someone who hasn't watched the film
uh basically he's a bad [__] insane
director okay yeah so I'm I'm gonna I'm
gonna say some scenes of Mind Games that
I remember out of context devil man cry
baby right there yeah
Devilman crybaby was what I think one of
his works that made the most amount of
sense yeah okay so even though so mind
game starts off with a guy confessing to
a girl
um and then I think the girl does
something he's in a bar and then he gets
shot
um and then he dies and he sees God who
is a goldfish
um who gives him another chance at life
he reincarnates and then he runs off
gets swallowed by a massive whale
and he lives in the whale's stomach for
like months and months with an old man
and a girl
um you're literally just bringing back
memories I was like I was like yes that
is in fact what happened and then they
they have this like dance scene this
this will this will live rent free in my
mind for ages they have this dance scene
where they have like massive poles
coming out of their dicks and they're
playing they're playing like hula with
it or something or some [__] like that
oh my God and then at the end of the
film he escapes the whale and uh that
was spoilers for mind game but is it
really spoilers
it's like it's gonna explain the next
JoJo part out of context it's like it
still doesn't make sense like that was
all out of context yeah that made no
sense in context I would say though ride
the wave is probably well I mean I think
with my game did he also co-write that
oh [__] I hope he did otherwise I'm
worried for whoever wrote my game but
basically right the wave is like I would
say it's probably one of the most uh
like cohesive USA films right um it's
it's very straightforward just like it's
a really cute film yeah um so basically
you make cute things yeah I know I was
actually also surprised I was like this
it was so cute to the point where it
didn't feel like a glass of film but uh
basically the story is uh the the main
goal is this like surfer chick
um and she meets this uh guy who's like
a firefighter one day and after he saves
her from a house fire yeah and then they
fall in love uh that you know they get
together and then the guys are spoiler
alert for right away uh the guy drowns
from a surfing accent and basically
she's really torn up about it because
like that was like her first film and
everything and then and then what
happens is and then what happens is is
that uh after that she starts to see
visions of him inside the water yeah so
the point where she can actually summon
him in like a water form out in the real
world and like interact with them as if
he was still alive
and it's basically this idea of like
it's cold right of the way because it's
kind of like a double entender of like
obviously right in the way of like
literally Surfer Dude hell yeah right
but it's also but it's also like riding
the wave of like your life of like you
know stuff happens [__] happens you miss
that first wave but the next wave is
Gonna Come so yeah you have to move on
with your life and it's a very like it's
a very simple straightforward like
romantic drama
um but obviously with like U.S uh
Aesthetics thrown into it so like the
character designs are very you are sir
yeah the animation style is just [__]
whacked out because science sorrow was
on some cracks as they usually are
um and yeah I'd say like it's definitely
not like a USA film but it had hints of
USA and I think it's probably the most
like approachable us of film if that
makes sense like I would show that over
something like you know uh to time a
Galaxy or something yeah I mean some of
his most approachable stuff it's
probably ping pong the animation and
Dove man cry baby yeah
um I'd say it's more approachable than
that to be honest oh really yeah I would
say like Aesthetics wise and just like
theming wise like if you've never heard
of a USA film I'd be like start off with
this and if you Vibe with this then you
can go to like Ping Pong or whatever why
does he want his [__] to be so ugly I
don't like why is ping pong as ugly as
it is oh on purpose I'd say so this is
like wean out like fake normally I mean
it's just it's just a [__] unique art
style the more the more the more I've
watched anime the more I [__] respect
it no I like it I like it but I just
wonder like God damn this is so ugly
like intentional yeah like why I mean I
think there are some pretty ugly moments
in the story you know where you kind of
like some you have some characters that
have this
realization that life is just [__]
shitty man life ain't Fair life ain't
shitty sometimes it's [__] ugly I
mean yeah I mean after like you know you
watch hundreds and thousands of shows
and movies like it's the it's the ugly
ones that you remember oh my God like I
just I like with the amount of anime I
like watched have watched over the bike
the past few years the amount of light
novel adaptations that looks that look
like a copy paste it's I'm [__] tired
of that [__] yeah it's like oh here's
Kirito clone number 307 for every light
novel protagonist looks the [__]
saying so do the waifus as well it's the
same it's always the same bright light
novelist character designs and there's
no variation in it yeah at all and I
just like seeing something like you know
ping pong the animation uh likes of
mcfry baby it's just it's it's nice just
to see something different sometimes
yeah